hi everyone I'm valley from fat fashion
reviews and today's one minute monday is
going to be about the beauty and I'm not
talking about the beauty that we show on
the outside I'm talking about the beauty
that we all have inside and there's so
many different ways of defining the word
beauty to me it is super important to
feel beautiful first on the inside in
order to show the beautiful you on the
outside I started doing makeup about
five years ago and I started just by
doing it on myself and experimenting
with new products and different makeup
but then I realized that that's not what
I really wanted what I wanted was to be
able to share what I knew with others
and that's when I started doing makeup
on my friends and my family and then I
came to this idea that I wanted to start
my own YouTube channel to be able to
show many more people out there what I
knew so then i created my channel and i
started off by naming it five fashion
reviews and it's something that i really
enjoy doing just by knowing that I'm
helping other women out there feel more
beautiful and more confident really
helps me a lot and is that something
that's very important that you should do
what you love to do and do it with
passion makeup is something that I
really enjoy and love doing and I feel
like it's very important to follow your
dreams do what you like and don't let
anybody take that away from you so that
was my story I hope you guys enjoyed it
and don't forget believe hi everyone my
name is caleta red I recommend that you
try out Evan Carmichael's newsletters
they've helped me to restart my business
and realize my passion which is awesome
you